hi everyone i'm director
sato i'd like to take this opportunity
to tell you all about the much requested
extra game mode included in resident
evil village
the mercenaries for those of you hearing
about it for the first time
it's a beloved extra mode featured in
various games in the franchise
it's best known for high speed arcade
style action
where you have to reach the goal within
a certain time limit
of course we've also added some new
touches to it so let's dive into some of
the additions we've made
welcome the first change is that we've
added a shop
in this version of the mercenaries you
can access the duke's emporium between
areas you're free to purchase new
weapons with the money you collect
or upgrade your arsenal to fit your play
style
i saw you eyeing that one weapons
modifications and
thank you for your patronage
rest assured you can expect this side
note to be just as fast paced as the
previous installments
you'll have to consider which weapons
you'll take into each stage and how
you'll customize them
with a large arsenal of options to work
with it's up to the player to figure out
what strategy works best for them
another change is the addition of
abilities
abilities can increase the damage of
handguns
or increase your movement speed
they can also make your guard stronger
each increasing the player's
capabilities
acquire new abilities to employ your own
strategies
as you fight your way through each stage
[Applause]
the mercenaries in resident evil village
is a rich gameplay experience
full of surprises with special rewards
for those who persevere
if you're looking for an additional
challenge we hope you're excited for
this extra mode that's included with the
main game
it's a challenging and rewarding bonus
mode packed with content
so we hope everyone is looking forward
to it thank you so much for watching